[Music]
what I'm doing as a scientist as I'm
suggesting that well I'm trying to
understand a specific scientific problem
which is for me it's called a hard
problem of consciousness and I'm trying
to think of a theory of reality that
will allow me to solve this hard problem
of consciousness the problem is this we
have a lot of interesting data that
gives us correlations between certain
kinds of brain activity and certain
conscious experiences that we have so
for example we know that if I take a
powerful magnet called a trans Meg a
transcranial magnetic stimulator and
touch it to part of the skull that's
just next to an area called v4 and if I
inhibit my neural activity in that area
immediately
all color will drain from the left part
of my visual world I'll just see shades
of grey I'll still see color in the
right part of the visual world but not
in the left then you turn off the magnet
and color it comes flowing back in so
there's this very interesting
correlation between interference with
neural activity and in the cup
the right hemisphere and loss of certain
kind of conscious experience in the left
visual world we can do that with motion
if I put this stimulator over an area
called v5 I can turn off my ability to
experience motion in the left visual
field and it turns out that in in the
science of you know cognitive
neuroscience we've discovered scores
maybe hundreds of these kinds of
correlations so correlations are the raw
data this brain activity is correlated
with that conscious experience and well
of course correlations are not a theory
rooster crows are correlated with
sunrises but that's not a theory for
example does a rooster crow cause a
sunrise well no that's we would tend to
think it might go the other way but but
it's hard to go from correlations to a
genuine theory of what's causing it you
might say well so for example we know
that brain activity
that we can measure with EEG
electroencephalograms we can predict
your choices that you'll make in certain
cases your free will choices seven
seconds before you can tell me what
you're going to choose so here again
brain activity is cleanly correlated
with your experience
seven seconds later of a choice that
you're making so here again we have this
correlation and in this case you might
say well okay here clearly the theory is
the brain activity came first the
experience of feeling like you had a
free will choice came a few seconds
later
so clearly the brain activity had to
cause it and that's too quick another
example the counter example is if you
look at a train station a bunch of
people assemble at the train station a
few minutes later the train appears did
the people coming to the train station
cause the train to appear no they didn't
so even though the correlation is tight
every time a group of people appears a
train appears a few minutes later is not
the case that the people appearing cause
the train to appear there's some third
entity namely a train schedule as
coordinating bro both so we have to be
very very careful when we have
correlations that's not the same thing
as a theory and then the final example
is you might say well look when you
actually take that magnet and stimulate
area before or inhibit it you're
intervening and by intervening we can
actually figure out what's causing what
right so you turn off before color goes
away surely that shows that v4 causes
the color experience and that's also too
fast if I'm in a virtual reality game
like Grand Theft Auto and I've got a
steering wheel I can say look I can
intervene I can turn the steering wheel
to the left that will make the car turn
to the left therefore the the steering
wheel is real and it really does have an
effect on the real car no it's not
there's again a hidden reality of diodes
and resistors all the circuits that's
mediating this it only we only have the
fiction of intervening and in a fiction
of causality so the problem we have in
the hard problem of consciousness is
that
scientists have gotten dozens maybe
hundreds of these tight correlations we
do not have a theory we cannot explain
why neural activity is correlated with
conscious experiences in particular we
cannot for a single conscious experience
like say by conscious experience I mean
something really simple like having a
headache experiencing color that taste
of vanilla the theories that are
proposed are basically only believed by
the graduate students of the professor
who proposes them and and no theory
that's been proposed can even predict or
or specify the conditions for a single
experience like the taste of vanilla so
if you think that neural activity causes
the taste of vanilla precisely what
neural activity is causing the taste of
vanilla and how does it do it no one has
any idea or if they say that neural
activity is identical to the taste of
vanilla then as a scientist I want to
say okay tell me with mathematical
precision what exactly is the matter the
neural activity that's identical to
vanilla and why is it identical
I mean it's anybody can say anything you
know I can say the moon is identical to
two blue cheese and just stipulate it
presumably you need to give me some
reason why I should believe in the
identity so they can't specify the
identity and and much less say why the
identity should be plausible so that's
the problem we've got it's it's a really
deep open scientific problem and it's
very personal
we all have conscious experiences we
would like to understand what's and we
also we also have brains we'd like to
understand what's happening here what's
why are these correlations there for
more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
an ideas her III TV
you